okay let's get the latest update on the
Jamal Shoji situation fiasco call it
whatever you want the backstory of
course is that after Washington Post
journalist Jamal khashoggi disappeared
and was killed we first heard from the
President of the United States that it
could have been anyone it could have
been rogue killers
we then saw as the information continued
to build that in fact Saudi Arabia was
aware of what was going on with
Khashoggi may have been involved in the
planning of what was going on with
Khashoggi may have ordered the killing
of Khashoggi Donald Trump insisted on
siding with Saudi Arabia rather win than
with basically every other country and
our own intelligence agencies he
wouldn't accept the findings of the CIA
he wouldn't listen to the recording of
the killing of Shamal Kujo Shakur shoji
because it's a suffering tape as he
called it and so he's continued to sort
of play coy with it despite the pretty
obviously building evidence more and
more that Saudi Crown Prince Mohammed
bin Salman Al Saud was directly involved
we now have another level of information
and I alluded to it yesterday talking
about Lindsey Graham although I didn't
get a chance to dig into it which is
that the CIA has information suggesting
that 11 times Saudi Crown Prince
Mohammed bin Salman was personally in
touch with the murder team the group of
people 15 people who killed
Jamal Cujo GOG before and after the
killing at that Saudi consulate in
Istanbul Turkey this is a CIA assessment
that was obtained by The Wall Street
Journal Mohammed bin Salman was
communicating with Saud al Kitani who
was supervising that obviously if you
have 15 people in a killing team you
need a supervisor and so Dahl Kotani was
supervising that team and Mohammed bin
Salman according to the CIA was directly
in touch with him the CIA also has as
part of this assessment that Mohammed
bin Salman is responsible communication
between Mohammed bin Salman and
Associates back in August
of 2017 about how they might be able to
quote trap khashoggi and it was
specifically mentioned that if they
couldn't lure Khashoggi to Saudi Arabia
quote we could possibly lure him outside
Saudi Arabia and make arrangements which
is number one exactly what happened to
show G ended up ultimately being killed
at the Saudi embassy in Istanbul Turkey
a different country it lines up with the
reporting that khashoggi became a target
much earlier than initial reports
suggested actually becoming a target in
late 2016 when he criticized both the
favorable to the Saudis and favorable to
trump perspective on Iran and that that
is what initially put him on people's
radar and if Mohammed bin Salman is
talking about Jamal Jamal Khashoggi back
in August of 2017 that also supports
that hypothesis so Republican senators
were briefed the day before yesterday by
CIA director Gena Haspel they came away
basically with the conclusion that
Yashin Amal Khashoggi ordered the murder
and Republicans now are saying some of
them that there's no question about it
senator bob Corker who's a Republican
said quote I have zero question in my
mind that the crown prince ordered the
killing monitored the killing knew
exactly what was happening planned it in
advance if he was in front of a jury he
would be convicted in 20-30 minutes
guilty corker says that Donald Trump's
position on this issue is quote
unacceptable Lindsey Graham I already
told you says that there's not a smoking
gun there's a smoking saw and that you
have to be willfully blind not to come
to the conclusion that this was
organized and orchestrated by people
under the command of Mohammed bin Salman
so Pat this is what the Magnitsky Act is
for to sanction foreign government
officials and individuals implicated in
human rights abuses anywhere in the
world there are countless ways that this
could be used against the Saudis and I
would like to see it done I'm not
holding my breath Bertram
to do it though no absolutely not and of
course Trump is to the bitter end going
to stick to this idea that it could have
been rogue killers or it could have been
a 400-pound men on a bed somewhere I
mean if you're gonna suggest that you
gotta provide some evidence and the
problem is that we have you know dozens
of pieces of evidence that suggest that
could show that Mohammed bin Salman was
behind the murder of Jamal khashoggi and
there's nothing really to the contrary
people who are unsure about how we would
use the magnet ski act against Saudis
maybe don't know exactly how it works
the Magnitsky list individuals people
put on the Magnitsky list are personally
sanctioned okay that means they can't
come to the United States they can't do
business with American banking
institutions this would really hurt some
of these rich Saudis financial ease and
financially and it would also allow the
United States to freeze the assets that
some of these Saudis have in the United
States that could include assets that
were run through I don't know real
estate transactions involving oh maybe
the current president of the United
States Donald Trump and some of his
company so you don't have to look very
far I think the point is to figure out
personal impetus for Donald Trump not to
take this seriously and that's exactly
what he's doing make sure that you're
following the show on instagram at david
pakman show follow me on instagram while
you're there at david dot Pakman behind
the scenes pictures of the studio of the
Pat Cave of the whole thing we'll take a
quick break and be back after this one
of today's sponsors is Skillshare which
is an amazing online learning community
that offers thousands of high-quality
classes on almost any topic first 500
people who click the link under this
video will get two entire months of
totally free access to every single
class offered by Skillshare they've got
classes on everything from design video
editing photography business technology
cooking meditation even classes on
personal productivity I know you'll be
able to find some
on Skillshare that fascinates you or
even something that will help you in
your everyday life classes are taught by
real people who care about what they're
teaching I just took a really great
class on more advanced video editing
techniques the david pakman show is
giving you two months of free access to
every class they offer when you click
the link under this video
think about everything you'll have at
your fingertips for two whole months
totally free hard to beat and after that
if you like it you can keep access to
every class on Skillshare for under ten
bucks a month one of the most affordable
learning platforms out there just click
the link under this video to redeem your
to three months of Skillshare but hurry
it's only available to the first 500 who
sign up